[Music]
hey there and welcome to this series of
lessons in after effects
this is on keying rotoscoping and
transfer modes
like i said inside of after effects and
we're going to start with this first set
on king
and what is king king is very easy to do
inside of after effects if you know what
you're doing and it's easy to get an
initial key but it's a little bit more
challenging to get a refined key
so let's start with this simple example
here
in this example i've got some clouds
that are just kind of moving
you know they're moving footage
just kind of
going by the camera
and i've also got this green screen
footage here of a jet that goes across
the screen so
this is a cg render of a jet
over green in a case like this typically
it's
typically going to be a pretty perfect
key because this is a cg render when
you're shooting something over green a
lot of times you can get
things you have to deal with which can
be a little more challenging
which we'll look at here in a couple
more lessons but
what is going to be challenging about
this particular shot is this cockpit up
here because it's glass and i'll go
ahead and stop and back it up here
but you can see that we look we see
through the cockpit and we see some
green through there so
that's
what has to be figured out but it's
actually very easy to do
so what we're going to do to key inside
of after effects all you have to do is
go to
effect keying
and you're going to go down to key light
there's a few different ways that you
can key
i'm going to focus
more on
key light
so that you can really understand
how it works but we will get in a little
bit on luma keying as well
so for key light all you do is you apply
the effect
like so and then you just
pick the screen color a little
eyedropper here come over here and just
click
and boom look at that key
it almost looks perfect and to an
untrained eye
you think it is perfect it's like oh i
can you know everything's the
background's completely gone
i'm good to go but if you look very
closely
up in here
you're going to see it's not such a
perfect key
and
you'll really notice it when you play
this back on
larger screens and you start seeing some
artifacting happening in here
um if i back
this playhead up here
it's even a little bit hard to see here
on our playback but it is there and the
reason i know it's there
is
um
because of what's inside key light here
so
by default it's always going to show you
the final result which we see right here
this is the the default so again i'll
reset it
you come in you click and there's your
key that's what keylight is made to be
very simple straightforward but inside
of keylight there's a lot of options
for really going in and correcting
things but i find that for the most part
you don't really have to mess with too
much
inside of here but i am going to show
you what i i typically mess with so
uh what you can do is you can go into
where it says final result
there are some different options inside
of here
there is the source which is our
keyed footage there's a source alpha if
there is an alpha channel this one does
not have enough channel
there is the corrected source which we
see here and this is actually where you
start seeing
some of the things
happening so inside of here you can see
it doesn't look quite right right
um as we move down
further into this you're gonna start
seeing more things that don't look quite
right
screen matte is what i'm going to focus
on the most
and you can see some
fringy
artifacting going on here and that's
what we want to get rid of if you have a
mask you'll see that there inside
outside mask
which you set those up here
and here
we have the combined mat
which again you can see some artifacting
going on here we have the status
intermediate result
which
there you can really see the green
and we have the final result which pulls
that green out and
there we go so if i jump back here to
screen matte what i'm going to do is the
two things i typically mess with are
clip black and clip white okay sometimes
you will play around a little bit with
screen pre-blur and that kind of comes
into play
when you are
dealing with a key that maybe has some
wrinkles in the curtain maybe see some
wrinkles coming across here very slight
wrinkles if you use the screen blur
that is going to kind of blur
that background image and make the key
a little easier to get
so again i'm going to switch back here
to screen matte make sure my key light
is on and i'm just going to start i put
in very low values to start and you see
right when i put five you saw some
things disappear here
so you see those artifacts right there
as soon as i put a five in there
see how those went away
i can also jump down here to
intermediate results
and i can see it looks a little cleaner
um
let's go back to combined matte
a lot of those artifacts are gone
screen matte here we go so i'll go up to
10.
and i saw a little bit more of the edge
went away here
if i undo that because there's a little
bit more there you can also see it
pulled some some
of the mat here over the plane
and i'll actually go a little bit more i
find that 15
seemed to work pretty well for this one
if i go back here to combined matte
it's looking pretty good if i go back to
my final result here
so that's with a clip black of 15.
look pay attention to this right here if
i go back to zero
you can see up in here especially
it just got a little bit more muddy
if i undo it
it's just a little more clear through
here
i go back to zero
you can't really see
the artifacting going on here but
sometimes what i will do when i'm keying
something is i'll add a solid
i'll make it the comp size and i make it
a bright
red
and that's so i can easily see
artifacting if it happens to be going on
back here so if i turn this back to zero
so right there immediately i saw some
artifacting pop back in undo it back to
15 and watch this go away
see that
so just a couple things you just need to
be aware of when you're keying
that looks pretty good i'll turn off the
solid
go back to 100
and i will preview this
and it looks really nice something else
you always want to keep an eye out for
is
what's called spill light and that's
where the green is kind of reflecting in
the material in front of it that you're
shooting because this is a cg render we
don't see that
the cg render was probably added to the
green screen
and this was just a way for someone to
get stock footage maybe if they don't
know what alpha channels are
if they get it keyed then it's easy to
key and they can just use it that way
so there we go there is our first
keyed shot it looks pretty good to me
yeah it looks really nice
so you can see there that was pretty
simple to do let's move into the next
example
okay so for this next keying example
i'm not going to actually key this shot
out so i'm just frozen on a single frame
here
and if we were to key this
particular frame out we would still have
to roto
around this hand to remove some of these
tracking markers so i have the mask here
and i'm just going to go ahead and turn
that mask on and let's just pretend
actually let's subtract that let's
pretend that this is a key
okay because this is what happens when
you key this out or roto this out you're
still left with what is called spill
okay and you can see the spill from the
green light on the screen
is left here on this person's hand it's
just
that ambient light
from the green that has projected itself
onto this hand
how do you get rid of that without
keying it out because you don't want to
key this away this is the person's hand
you want to make sure it's there
so what you do
is you go back to effect
keying and the very first option here is
called advanced spill suppressor so
remember we worked with key light before
now we've got advanced spill suppressor
when we apply that watch what happens to
the green
see how it immediately went away
and now it looks like the color of maybe
a screen
maybe more of a blue light so it's it's
very quick
it's a plug-in that's meant to be
applied and it immediately does its job
if you want even more control over it
you can go into ultra mode
and ultra mode allows you to
sample
the green
and i'll go ahead and turn this off and
i'll sample the screen
and i'll turn the mask back to subtract
turn this on and there you go so now we
have just a really nice
uh almost like a white light here and if
i want to actually remove even a little
bit more green from the hand here i can
do that
by turning either
like the tolerance up or the saturation
up so tolerance if i turn this up a
little bit
so there's 100 percent
and there's 50
and you just have to really kind of be
careful because you can notice that it's
desaturating the entire image to do that
so you can also expand the spill range
adjust the color correction
so there you go so there's with spill
suppressor and there's without you can
see a significant difference
in that green
that is
being projected onto the hand a lot of
times like i said whenever you shoot
something in front of a green screen
there's typically what depending on what
you're shooting it could be a lot of
spill or a little bit of spill if you
have a lot of reflective material
there's a lot of spill that happens
if the subject is or the object is very
close to the screen a lot of spill can
happen as well
okay so in this shot we have man's
favorite friend the cat
so
cats always make me laugh every time i
see a cat
anyways so here we have a cat and we've
got a few things going on with this cat
that can typically be very challenging
with king
one of them the biggest one is actually
the very fine hair that you see here the
whiskers from the cat
um
there
can be challenging
to key out and then of course when the
cat moves like that
um it can typically be a problem as well
so i think this is a slow motion shot
yeah it is a slow motion shot so how
would i approach keying out this shot
with a lot of hair
well let me show you how i would do this
so what i would do
is i've also got a background layer
applied here that i'm going to show you
so we've got this background here
and that's we're going to put behind the
cat
but the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go up to
effect king
and key light
and i do want to mention of course i
have a ton of plugins
um you're not going to have all these
plugins so you might see above here it
says key correct above king and you may
say well where's my key correct where
are these tools this is actually another
set of plugins i've purchased separately
that i occasionally use for very tough
keys but it's not something that you
need to worry about
all you need to focus on is just keying
so
here we have key light and again it
defaults to black and it defaults to
black i think because
so that we don't have any results when
we immediately apply it
because if it defaulted to a green the
green would disappear but maybe it's not
the right green every shade of green
screen is gonna be slightly different
so you'll
actually let's go ahead and undo that
you'll notice that this
green
is not quite as
green as this one was
so see how that's a very vibrant green
and
the green right now is more of a
desaturated green so we're going to go
ahead and select the green and we're
going to get close to the
subject and there we go and you can
immediately see the artifacting that's
happening right here a lot a lot of
artifacting that depends on
your shot it depends on the codec that
was used to record
your footage it depends on how much
compression is happening
all that kind of stuff so this
shot this digital shot seems to have
quite a bit of artifacting going on
which can be very bad
for us but uh hopefully we'll get it
sorted out so the next thing we're gonna
talk about is an another powerful effect
inside a king
and this is
called
key cleaner and this thing is a godsend
watch what happens when i click on key
cleaner watch what happens up here
just the default settings
got rid of all that noise up in there
but now we can also adjust these
settings and get a little bit better
results
so turning that down to five it was d at
10 and if you look i'm looking really
closely here at these edges a lot of
times with king you want to get very
close in on your subject matter
so we'll reduce that to half and it just
pulls out a little bit more of the
artifacting that's going on and we're
going to turn up the contrast
let's turn it up to 10.
20.
let's go up to 25.
so now it's starting to look pretty good
there's still a little bit going on in
these areas here but some of this stuff
is going to be hidden once we put a
background behind there but let me show
you something that you do want to do
here
so that we don't have to deal with like
this area of the frame that's not keying
out
something like this what we're going to
do is we're actually going to mask that
out
set that to subtract
and maybe also in here
something you need to also pay attention
to when you do use masks like this you
want to make sure that your subject
matter
never
passes
through this through the mask
okay so now it's playing and i can see
that i'm in the safe zone
the closest the cat gets is right in
here
yeah and it does cut it off right there
so if we move the mask up there we
should be good to go
some things that you need to also be
aware of um when adding or when looking
at these edges um like i said this shot
has a lot of fringing going on there are
things like edge color correction that
can help with the uh
getting cleaned up a little bit
so now we can look at with the
background added in and see if some of
this stuff is still really present or
not and you can see a lot of it just
goes away
with that background added so what i
have here is just an image
if i double click it's just a stock
image i pulled off
a website and what makes it work is
obviously you don't want it to be in
focus like this because the cat
is completely out of focus at this point
or not the edges of the cat are
blurry so i would go to a part here
and you can see things are very blurry
here
along the edge
really shallow depth of field so i found
um i used the fastbox blur i cranked it
up to 40
and turned it on and there you go
uh typically i would use like a camera
lens blur for something like this if i
had the time to render it
it looks a little bit nicer but for this
example
it works just great so
something else i'd probably do is go
into a hue and saturation
maybe drop the saturation
just a little bit
so that's negative five yeah it's just a
teeny little bit
so it looks pretty good there's always
things that we could do to continue to
make masks uh
keying better and better there's also
additional tools available for us to as
motion designers to improve them but a
lot of times we can get away with
basic keying like in this instance and
making it look okay
something that i do notice
so if you go up in here and you zoom in
you're going to see right here now watch
out so i turn key cleaner off
see how much more noise appears there
so
something you could also do is keep key
cleaner on and then increase the black
just a little bit and it brings
maybe a 10 here
yeah that looks really nice
helped clean up the edges just a little
bit more
and by increasing that clip black just a
little bit it helps really clean up
those edges and that artifacting that
happen
right up along the edges here so it
looks really nice it's a good key it'll
work for us next we're going to move on
to the luma key